Where are we?
Paris, 2010 A.D.,...
...and this is the mighty Musee D'Orsay,...
...home to many of the greatest paintings in history.
Oh, that's wonderful.
Ignore that.
I've got something more important to show you.
I just wondered, between you and me, in 100 words,...
...where do you think Van Gogh rates in the history of art?
Well, big question,...
...but to me, Van Gogh is the finest painter of them all,...
...certainly the most popular, great painter of all time,...
...the most beloved.
His command of color, the most magnificent.
He transformed the pain of his tormented life into ecstatic beauty.
Pain is easy to portray, but to use your passion and pain...
...to portray the ecstasy and joy and magnificence of our world,...
...no one had ever done it before.
Perhaps no one ever will again.
To my mind, that strange, wild man who roamed the fields of Provence...
...was not only the world's greatest artist...
...but also one of the greatest men who ever lived.
Vincent, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, is it too much?
No, they are tears of joy.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Sorry about the beard.